I'm of uh the belief that uh I meet
someone I talk to them for a while and I
think I know they've always been this
person you've always been calling you're
this funny uh charismatic guy when do
you realize as a young man as a kid that
yeah uh acting act I wanna I want to do
that I have a facility for that that's
what I'd like to do and was there
another option not a real legit other
option you know uh maybe if I had
learned that 10th guitar chord then
maybe the bands I had been in in high
school and college would have worked out
a little bit more but I mean there was
really no like safety net it to be
honest it really just came down to it
was the most fun acting was the thing
that I was I was drawn to the most and
when there was the least amount of
pressure on me to enjoy it that was when
I enjoyed it the most and you know there
was a period there
where it seemed like everyone was like
well of course that's what you're going
to do and so of course there was that
sort of like young man version of like
well no I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna
smoke pot all day and watch television
instead and that'll show you like there
was no right there there was no other
like real option but it really it and
you know this is the one thing I will
sort of credit credit the old man with
um is he said like look you have to want
to do this
if you don't really want this then come
up with something else like because you
will be miserable if this is not
something that you truly are passionate
about yes and it was the best advice
that I could have have gotten at the
best time because I enjoyed it so much
that I couldn't see myself doing
anything else and yet I also had no idea
what it was actually really going to
entail and what it was really going to
be like and you know
months of unemployment and self-doubt
and fear and just so much other you know
kind of there's so much other stuff that
sort of forces a lot of people to just
say like I'm out I I don't want to deal
with I don't want to feel like this
anymore and the truth of the matter is I
enjoy
I enjoy what I do
so much that when it's great I don't
want to do anything else right not only
do I not see myself doing it like I
don't want to do anything else you're
preaching to the choir because I very
clearly remember
um
you know I got into comedy writing and
then got a chance to do a sort of a
stage show comedy review in Chicago in
1988 tiny theater not great reviews
um uh you know brutally hot living in a
driving a crappy car living in an
apartment on the North side that had no
air conditioning
um and realizing that I was as happy as
I could possibly be yeah and that this I
you know whatever this is where you
where you're backstage and then there's
some music and then you come out and
there are people and you get some laughs
I will do this uh if it leads nowhere
completely and and I do think that there
is something about I I often have the
same advice for people
and I'm going to link this to our next
topic which I know is near and dear to
your heart
um but uh
there are some people that so get caught
up in I want to do something because I
get to be famous yeah this looks like
it's going to be a great lifestyle
and sure there's nice things about that
but you really have to like the thing
itself yeah because there's a
95 chance or for some people a 99 chance
that the other stuff isn't going to come
and then you really do have to enjoy the
process oh yeah because
more often than not the process could be
a pain in the ass and and like not a
great experience sometimes
sometimes you know I've been on on on
you know I've been on jobs where it's
less than ideal you know it is way too
hot it is I am way too tired it is
physically exhausting pornography
well but I really enjoy that in the
moment yeah but this is what people
don't understand about pornography
there's a lot of standing and waiting
around there is there's a lot I'm sorry
there is there there are not stand-ins
which that Love Actually movie really
pushed a false narrative there there are
no stand-ins in pornography so I'm told
yeah um but it it can be a very very
challenging job like in in the moment
well but if you love that you will
Overlook that and you will Overlook all
of the other little things that are uh
uh that can be frustrating and can bring
you down and can distract you and if
there's a specific kind of person I find
there are some people that really thrive
on that and they love to complain and
they love to do this and they love to do
that and there was a period where I was
definitely more of that ilk
um but I the the thing that I always uh
really admire about just the profession
of acting is that at no point will
everyone say
I've got it I've done it I've learned
everything there is to learn exactly I
so I am constantly
trying to look at okay well what are the
new ways that I can go about things what
what what how can I approach this job
how can I approach this role how like
how can I make this as an enjoyable
thing as I can because I remember uh
Jake kazden who directed Orange County
and and is an old friend of mine he he
but you were in with Jack Black with
Jack yeah yeah and uh he had written me
this really sweet another letter writer
he had written me a very nice letter at
the end of it and he said you know
you and I both are cut from the same
cloth because we both understand that
this could be the best job in the world
if you make it that right it can also be
the worst and I've I've sometimes made
it the worst you know so so I I always
want to try and do everything I can to
to you know look I'm not saying I'm
gonna be like rah-rah like all right
guys come on let's go like it doesn't
have to be that but I enjoy it so much
that I want to try and make it as as as
as as as as as as good as I can because
look we all went and ran away and joined
the circus I know right so like let's
like enjoy that because I could be
punching a clock right now and be really
miserable and not like like anything
that I'm doing so I I'm always trying to
do whatever I can to to try and make it
an enjoyable experience Because the
actual doing of the thing actually gives
gives me gives me joy